hey GQ I'm Dr Eric Bender a psychiatrist
and psychotherapist and today I'll be
looking at some patients from a galaxy
far far away this is the mental
breakdown
Emperor Palpatine I have said it many
times
you are the most gifted Jedi I have ever
met
thank you your Excellency I see you
becoming the greatest of all the Jedi
Anakin
even more powerful than Master Yoda
Emperor Palpatine has been grooming
Anakin Skywalker to be his right-hand
Sith he has taken steps that we often
see with sexual predators trying to
groom younger kids so that the Predators
can actually interact with them sexually
one of the first stages is to identify
who you're going to groom what the
Predator often does is look to see if
there's some kind of psychological need
or what the Predator might think of as a
weakness that will allow the Predator to
come in Anakin's psychological need is
to have a father figure and he thinks he
has that with Obi-Wan what the emperor
does is moves in on that territory and
starts to develop this relationship with
Anakin so he identifies Anakin he then
starts to isolate him and move him away
from the people that he does know from
the Jedi he starts to talk to him about
how I know these secrets of the dark
side he tempts Anakin all of the fears
that he has he'll know the dark side
Anakin
if one is to understand the great
mystery one must study all its aspects
not just the dogmatic narrow view of the
Jedi if you wish to become a complete
and wise leader you must Embrace a
larger view of the force
be careful of the Jedi Anakin he's
having these conversations with Anakin
to show I can help you so he's
establishing an identity for himself as
someone that Anakin can trust another
stage of grooming is getting the trust
of the child in this case Anakin's a
teenager I hope you trust me Anakin
of course
I need your help son
what do you mean
I'm depending on you
for what I don't understand to be the
eyes ears and voice of the Republic As
you move forward in grooming with a
sexual predator what you would see is
that the Predator then escalates the
behavior with the child
starting to then have accidental touches
maybe bumping the bodies or bumping of
elbows and then that escalates into more
sexual contact so there's been a gradual
escalation
Emperor mirrors that not with sexual
contact but with information to Anakin
saying hey I know you have these
concerns and and I can help you with
them at first it's very informal and
then here we see the formal invitation
to finally separate and have this
relationship with the emperor he's
saying come fulfill your destiny and
here we see Anakin saying I'll do
whatever so he has gone through the
stages of grooming Anakin and Anakin is
now going to become as we know Darth
Vader
become my Apprentice
learn to use the dark side of the force
I will do whatever you ask
good
in the case of the emperor he as they
learn more about his character if he
were to come in and see me more and more
if I had some records I would see that
he is more of a psychopath psychopath is
someone who doesn't care innately about
other individuals just uses them to get
what they want the emperor enacted Order
66 killing all in the Jedi showing he
doesn't really care about any of these
individuals all the people in his Empire
are really just pawns for him to get
what he wants which is power and that's
what he's using Anakin for
Obi-Wan
with my brother Anika
oh we wanted promised Qui-Gon that he
would lead Anakin through Jedi training
to complete it so there's this idea of
Obi-Wan's master or father figure
Qui-Gon and now Obi-Wan becomes the
master teacher or father figure for
Anakin so even though he's saying he's a
brother or saw him as a brother it could
be a different type of relationship I
often will see in Psychotherapy someone
will have a frame of reference for how
they see someone in their lives but as
we talk more we realize that maybe that
relationship meant something different
maybe it meant something more than the
way someone is describing and I think
that's what's happening here this was
more of a sun so contrasting the death
of parents with Mando to the death of a
child here
the death of a child is devastating to
any parent and it's really just crushing
in this case Obi-Wan goes on and we see
that he really is still fixated on the
death of Anakin
promise me
don't make me kill you
[Music]
do not fear the dark side
[Music]
Jedi
even when you have lost somebody and you
do go from acute grief to more
integrated grief it's still painful to
think of somebody gone you still have a
sadness about them but you can actually
think of them without being crushed
everyone hasn't gotten there
so this is really about grief this is
not about depression Darth Vader
don't try to frighten us with your
sorcerer's ways Lord Vader your sad
Devotion to that ancient religion has
not helped you conjure up the stolen
data tapes or giving you Clairvoyance
enough to find the rebels hidden fort
all right I find your lack of faith
disturbing
Darth Vader is showing some signs of
narcissistic personality disorder so
personality disorder refers to how
somebody interacts with the world around
them and is called a disorder if it's
vastly different from the cultural norm
and what's expected narcissistic
personality disorder or narcissistic
traits reflect a need to feel a certain
respect need to feel important it
reflects in some cases a lack of empathy
for other people there's a inability to
tolerate someone not praising you or not
doing things the way you absolutely feel
they should be done because you are so
important there's an exaggeration of how
important you are we see some of those
traits here when Darth Vader trying to
strangle this person he can't tolerate
being questioned he's also trying to put
this person in his place by nearly
killing him some narcissists in the most
extreme cases show this lack of empathy
what's very interesting underneath of a
narcissism like this is there is quite a
fragility
and if you did peel back and get
underneath the Darth Vader's layers
there there's Anakin Skywalker and
remember how fragile he was thinking he
was going to lose his wife thinking he
was going to lose his kids there's this
narcissistic fragility that those around
the narcissist aren't necessarily aware
of but those individuals around
narcissists I see this all the time when
I see folks in therapy they feel like
they have to make this person happy or
something dire will happen not
necessarily they're going to be
strangled by the force but they're
actually going to have to
deal with something really bad so a
narcissist has a way of making people
around them feel they got to do
something they got to make sure that
person's emotions are okay and the
interesting thing is the individual
thinks it's because I'm so important
everybody should serve me but it's
because they're so fragile people around
them are sensing that if they don't take
care of that person's emotions this
person's gonna fall apart
and it's really really burdensome to
people when Anakin's a teenager we see
that he has some of the qualities of
what is known as borderline personality
disorder borderline personality disorder
reflects that pull between the psychotic
or a break from reality in the neurotic
which has to deal with really trying to
manage anxiety but as a teenager you
can't necessarily diagnose somebody or
shouldn't necessarily diagnose somebody
with borderline personality disorder
particularly in their early teen years
some of that behavior is actually
expected as people grow and learn to
deal with their emotions also it's
important to state that people with
personality disorders are not
necessarily inherently violent or evil
it's interesting that the Jedi I don't
think they'd be great psychotherapists
they decide that Anakin's too cloudy and
don't really want to deal with him in
some ways early on when Yoda is arguing
saying no the boy's too clouded the
boy's got too much going on Obi-Wan's
trying to help Anakin understand things
differently but also remember Anakin's
getting bombarded with these other ideas
from Emperor Palpatine so there's
there's a push and a pull the moment
Darth Vader throws the emperor into the
electrical field at the end of Return of
the Jedi is a moment that audiences
cheered on there's a reuniting there of
a father and a son it's a very moving
scene in some ways it's like the field
of electrical dreams it's somewhat
hollywoodized and that they're trying to
move the Audience by saying all right
here's his father's been so moved by his
son and is there to step in and help his
son he really embodies the Force for
good in that moment the Jedi were about
peace and stability and in that moment
Darth Vader has reestablished the
relationship with his son he's
established a piece and a calmness even
if it's short-lived because Darth Vader
is about to die but there is in that
moment this bond with a father and a son
I see people whose parents are deceased
and have long been deceased and they
still wish they could have that
relationship with their parent that they
never had it's an innate drive for us
from our very early ages to want to
please our parents to want to be with
our parents in a certain way when you
become a parent there's also an innate
drive to actually want to be with your
kids and want to see them love and make
them feel loved here's the moment when
Darth Vader has that kicking the
Mandalorian
[Music]
make sure he's protected
so in the Mandalorian you see the main
character Mando as most people call it
really develop a bond with grogu the
baby
the baby Amanda himself comes from a
place where he has a lot of trauma his
parents tried to hide him during an
invasion and as they hit him and then
left him there they were killed he was
then rescued by mandalorians and they
took him in
what's interesting is when a child loses
a parent studies show that in the first
year or two just in those first two
years those children are at higher risk
for depression or anxiety than other
children who've lost no one
but over a seven year study when they
looked ahead they found that at any
point those children could develop
post-traumatic stress disorder or PTSD
and post-traumatic stress disorder means
that there's been an event a traumatic
event there's some re-experiencing of
the event maybe through dreams or
flashbacks when you actually think
you're back in that moment at that time
it's not just a memory but you really
feel like you're back there you have a
hyper vigilance kind of looking around
making sure that everything's okay and
there might be an avoidance too
avoidance of situations or from certain
places that make you remember the trauma
seems like Mando has some of those
characteristics of trauma certainly
Mando doesn't necessarily have a full
diagnosis of post-traumatic stress
disorder but he has enough of the
criteria to suggest he's certainly
dealing with trauma when a child loses
both parents like that often someone can
come in and offer a nurturing
environment
when he was adopted by the mandalorians
he was adopted by that Orthodox group
that ended up really focusing on this is
the way and really abiding to the Creed
so interestingly he doesn't end up
developing personal relationships which
could really help a child deal with the
trauma so it's almost as if he's
re-traumatized where he then comes to
this group that doesn't even want to
show their faces to each other they have
the best guard medal on so he continues
to have this trauma of not having a
nurturing relationship so it's such a
striking difference when he ends up
seeing grogu and really engaging with
him
Kroger
yes
[Music]
that's his name
grogu
Ard he's laughing and just enjoying this
engagement this is something completely
new for him to have that kind of a
relationship so it's an interesting
thing to see The Chronic post-traumatic
stress or The Chronic
trauma that he's enduring what that does
to him
is it makes him have shallow
relationships he doesn't know how to go
deep with people
and it can also make him very suspicious
now granted he's a bounty hunter he's
going to be suspicious of everybody and
he's not going to trust anybody or
develop relationships with them he's
focused on his work but in some ways I'm
questioning does he go to that work
because of the way he grew up we all
have relationships and we all have
experiences in our lives early in our
lives as children and throughout that
really color how we interact with the
world if you look at Mando's experiences
he clearly is distant separated he wears
a mask almost the whole time
one of the episodes shows him not
wearing his mask he is really anxious
you could see the anxiety on his face he
doesn't know how to have these kinds of
relationships or interactions with
people for someone who becomes a
mercenary or a bounty hunter
there does seem to be some way to
compartmentalize some individuals might
have what's called cognitive dissonance
when they have to do a job that is going
to be pretty difficult so if someone's
actually trying to kill an individual
then in order to make it seem like
they're not killing a person they can
refer to that person that's a job or a
Target or a case or the next thing they
need to accomplish Mando does talk about
jobs and cases things like that
that's one coping strategy also some
individuals are psychopathic
they don't care about anybody they'll
become Hit Men or hit women and it's not
a problem for them Mando does not fall
into that campus Psychopaths he's
actually really developing a loving
caring relationship with baby Yoda
isoka
I cannot train him what
why not you've seen what he can do his
attachment to you makes him vulnerable
to his fears
his anger all the more reason to train
him no
[Music]
seen what such feelings can do to a
fully trained Jedi Knight
of us
here we see Ahsoka having her own
traumatic response to seeing grogu
ing she's thinking automatically of
Anakin when she said I've seen what
anger can do I've seen what these kinds
of emotions can do and how they get in
the way of training a Jedi
that was incredibly traumatic for
everybody to have the rise of Darth
Vader and Order 66 carried out people
just died there was a decimation of the
Jedi so she's responding appropriately
at the same time it's important to know
that in reality
feelings are messy sometimes people can
be very scared of feelings that's what
holds people back from coming to therapy
sometimes they're not sure what they're
going to discover how am I going to
handle this this is just going to crush
me but that's what a therapist is for is
to help you figure that out one of the
backstories involves Ahsoka being around
age three and being seen as very Force
sensitive and force powerful and the
Jedi were going to come and train her
but latrons an imposter who is actually
a bounty hunter ends up intercepting
this message or going and taking Ahsoka
away and using Ahsoka for their own
selfish needs this is really dramatic
and terrifying to Ahsoka so much so that
when she is actually eventually saved
when she goes on the train with the Jedi
she gets nervous she has a lack of
confidence she's really really scared
the council didn't trust me so how can I
trust myself
what about me
I believed in you I stood by you
I know you believe in me Anakin and I'm
grateful for that
but this isn't about you
I can't stay here any longer
not now this moment where she's saying I
need to leave the council doesn't trust
me it could hearken back to Memories she
might have after she was with latrons
and the Imposter so that she didn't
believe in herself then
she was duped who can she believe who
can she trust how could she trust
herself here we see maybe that happen
again often in our lives there might be
a traumatic event that happens or
something really difficult something
we've had to deal with it to find us in
some way creates a view we have of
ourselves
and then other things throughout life
push on that like a scar or a scab it
just lifts it a little bit picks it a
little bit this probably presses on that
moment for her she doesn't feel trusted
she's not someone who can be trusted
because she ended up falling in with
this imposter how can anybody ever trust
her so this is bringing up an old wound
for her later as we see in the
Mandalorian we see her more as an adult
she has gotten over those confidence
issues yet she's also nervous and
appropriately so given her background
and what's recently happened to the Jedi
when she sees that grogu has this
attachment to the Mandalorian at the
same time she's a very powerful figure
and will look forward to seeing how she
does in her own series
Jawa
so a bunch of these guys were just in
here and I actually can't find my
computer but I'd be curious as to what's
going on with them these Jawa are
actually not kleptomaniacs yes they
steal things but there's a difference
between kleptomania and stealing things
for a different purpose kleptomania is
an impulse control disorder it means
that you have these feelings urged to
steal something usually not of any
monetary value something doesn't really
matter to you you go ahead and steal it
it's this urge to do it and you have to
answer to it stealing the way the Jawa
do they're stealing because they're
selling things they're wanting money
that's a big difference between
kleptomania and actually stealing for
purposes of just getting money and being
able to trade things in we see them hit
anybody who's around so R2D2 is a victim
we later see the Mandalorian Mando stuff
is stripped and he has to bargain to get
it back so they're just out to get money
if you have kleptomania there could be
different time phases of that you can
have brief episodes with long periods of
not stealing anything you can have maybe
a short time when there's consecutive or
consistent stealing and then a short
time when there's none and then and you
can have a chronic kleptomania where it
just keeps going and going and going but
it isn't impulse control disorder so you
help someone figure out when they have
that impulse what that's about there
might also be what's called comorbid or
also existing at the same time
depression or anxiety so you want to
look and make sure that that's not going
on too something that also distinguishes
the jawa's behavior from kleptomania is
in kleptomania those individuals often
feel some guilt after they've done this
I've seen teenagers just with an
outpouring of Tears when they have
recognized what they're doing so that
element is completely missing from the
Jawas as you can see in the Mandalorian
they're ruthlessly negotiating to get
money for what they've stolen in terms
of other things to think about these
aren't pre-planned stealing episodes if
it's kleptomania it's in the moment and
the Jawa clearly planets they're hiding
out waiting for R2D2 to come by often
the guilt that people can share over the
kleptomania is not about being caught
it's not a sadness they got caught it
can really be as sad as this is going on
for them that they're dealing with this
the Jawa have no remorse whatsoever in
Obi-Wan Kenobi also we see them saying
well we gotta feed my family so
Obi-Wan's buying back parts that the
Jawa stole from him too kylo Ren
kylo Ren formerly Ben solo and then
again kylo Ren and Ben solo is actually
a very interesting character from a
young age he was with Leia and Han as
parents
the way that that relationship is
depicted in the movie is very very
contentious Han as we know is off
gallivanting throughout the Galaxy and
Leia's at home what that does to a child
sometimes to see parents fighting all
the time because they comment that they
weren't a great couple to see that kind
of fighting at such a young age it's
very hard for a young child not to think
that they have something to do with that
that they might be the cause of this
that if they were only good enough or
better were just good maybe their
parents wouldn't be fighting maybe Ben
would be enough for his dad to make him
stay so we see that he from a young age
likely had this idea developing him that
he wasn't good Ben then goes off to
Luke's Jedi training camp and when he's
there
he wakes up one night with Luke over him
with the lightsaber ready to kill him
if Luke thinks wait this guy's gonna
destroy the Galaxy I have to end him so
that's probably another confirmation to
Ben that he's really bad he's just not a
good kid he's not good at all children
are very intuitive they're going to pick
up on what their parents think even if
the parents aren't stating them hey
you're a loser you're this you're that
what is non-verbally communicated kids
will pick up and they will
react and act to the lowest bar the
parent sets so if the parent thinks this
kid's not going to be anything he's
going to be horrible that's what they're
going to feel they are going to be so
when it does come down to a choice like
Good and Evil
it's gonna be already pre-primed for
this kid to think he's evil and to do
something like kill his father or to
become a Sith Lord seeing Ben in therapy
would be really interesting and make
sure I be on my best behavior so as not
to get my head sliced off but I think it
would be interesting to find out from
him
what are the feelings you've had buried
tell me about this anger anger is a
really difficult emotion for people to
deal with so I would sit with him in
Psychotherapy just asking him what was
it like what were the feelings that you
had what's the anger that you do have
towards your father tell me about that
relationship I'd want to know more from
him I have a feeling nobody has listened
to him that is the problem from the
beginning if people had listened to him
then he would feel like there was a
place for him in this family but that
wasn't the case well I see our time's up
so I will plan to see you at our next
appointment